2,5 milliards de plus c'est le coût des
normes qui sont applicables aux
collectivités territoriales on va parler
de d'équipement sportifs par exemple
quand on demande toujours plus de mise
aux normes pour les vestiaires pour
tout ce qui est électrique les normes
changent très souvent et à chaque fois
il faut pour être aux normes et de
valider au niveau des systèmes de
sécurité il y a des coûts
supplémentaires pour le pour les
collectivités l'inflation normative
d'abord retarde les projets complexifie
les projets on met parfois un mandat
voire plus pour monter des projets
d'envergure alors que dans les pays nos
pays voisins en trois ans souvent
l'Allemagne arrive à mettre en place des
projets parce qu'il y a une
simplification qui est qui est faite à
la base
[Musique]
nous avons proposé 5 recommandations à
travers notre notre rapport sur la
simplification d'abord un donner plus de
visibilité
sur la problématique des normes en
faisant en sorte que le gouvernement en
début de session nous propose un débat
parlementaire en séance pour nous
expliquer quelles sont les
réglementations nouvelles
tous les aspects normatifs qui vont être
procédés au niveau des collectivités
locales ou territoriales pour l'année
qui vient la deuxième chose c'est qu'il
faut que les études d'impact soit fait
bien en amont des textes de loi
troisièmement
il faut absolument que le CNN est
davantage de de moyens aujourd'hui
travail avec trois ou quatre personnes
pour étudier les textes on leur donne le
texte parfois la veille ou l'avant
veille avant qu'il soit étudié en séance
je crois qu'il faut vraiment que le CNN
est beaucoup plus de poids et de moyens
pour mettre en oeuvre
l'étude des textes et puis à une autre
recommandation que nous avons fait c'est
de mettre en place une veille au Sénat
dans chaque commission de mettre un
référent
qui soit vraiment spécialisé sur la sur
les normes et qui puissent justement
bien en amont faire remonter les
problématiques pour que on évite au
moment de la discussion des textes de
loi qu'on en rajoute une couche quoi
c'est l'objectif c'est qu'on est
vraiment une veille solide au Sénat pour
que on puisse éviter parfois des normes
qui nous coûte cher qui complexifient
qui retarde les projets